have your attention please we received  some extremely sad news from the  Evergreen County Sheriff  Bryce Walker was found and has been  confirmed dead some Irish to find the  person who killed my son we are working  every angle and we will find out what  happened someone might know could have  done this that's crazy this is Bryce  Walker did hurt a lot of people the one  he hurt the most was Jessica Davis  somebody shot rice Tyler has a gun  why'd you tell me I swear nothing you  don't know everything  okay clay you hated Bryce I think one in  bed  no rice hurt you do you know anything I  found this  I didn't do anything but the police  think that you did  no you need talker I got you  where were you that night tell me can  you help for every minute if you're  trying to clear your name you need to  look a little closer to home  [Music]  I know I should have said something  earlier  but I have to now  this whole [ __ ] world is better  without a minute what did you do  [Music]  you